we're here with the great John Brenkus I
want to start this podcast with first of
all just thanking everybody for writing
these great emails about my quantum
quote skin so it's almost over everyone
yeah hey I want your thick of your
headweight a dermatologist and you know
he was like that nurse told me one thing
the term talks goes what yes
no I don't want you to stay out of the
Sun it's just something you've got you
got a spot from a sunburn that I took
off it's not the kind of metastasizes
it's a [ __ ] mark you know these
nurses tell you so there are people out
there who are battling real issues their
realtor and like my dear friend Cass he
reached out to me I want to thank her
and she's dealing with issues that are
far more complex and serious than some
[ __ ] that I'm talking did you feel
like an [ __ ] when you say that
RealFlight I think I did I was very
nervous you [ __ ] did it did I did you
all really well do not lie and nothing
fancy just see in cancer salient oh my
god no if you don't mind it's about now
but no it is I do have his knee already
like do I do like did you get it out the
other tape man yeah you got an outgoing
got skin butter on my back I did you
have squeamish the rats are but yeah
yeah he looks like a [ __ ] beekeeper
what the [ __ ] are you do I sound like
this
yeah I'd say to him that can't be in the
Sun yeah meanwhile a doctor was like no
I want you in the Sun don't be
ridiculous just wear sunblock I was like
I know but I got two egos but listen to
me I took off a tiny piece from probably
you got to skip that couple bad summers
or maybe a hundred sunburn and it's
relaxed it's not the end of the world
got dark too I welcome is when you hear
can I get a bag sell make me realize a
lot of stuff I gotta get going man
gotta keep not you start living my life
off yeah right that bump on your back
yeah I'm asking about traveling you know
yeah yeah right how did you know how did
our grandparents do it like how did they
actually my great-grandfather lived till
93 they may have enough fill out a job
job they were like oh look I just have a
bump on my back that's discolored he
never got to take it off your whining
whatever has a [ __ ] the board on her
face which here's
she don't give very [ __ ] yeah what I
heard you said what this fancies I do
not not stupid now you go you should go
and I definitely had something it was it
was screaming self a little defensive
about this no that's a back the Lions
Alan can't rely on you [ __ ] what I'm
saying you know Daisy to shut up well
what I'm saying is that all you got to
do is take something like that off and
what this this concept is so small and
beginning but it could be a big day yeah
let it go a but also you'd only have
some fun comedy I'm probably thank you
also also careful how you listen to
[ __ ] nurses it's just like dude hey
don't give me a half information all
right well the protocol now is well
here's my sheet and I need to check my
boxes because the doctor said I go
looking and say your levels are low here
is medicine or here's an herb or here's
or whatever in the nursing I just have
to play right along if they've lost
their otoño how about this I get the
nurse who says what I thought I call him
I gotta go for my you go for a check-up
I'm safe right
I haven't to check them in two years I'm
[ __ ] lazy about that stuff I go to
get my checkup and when I take they take
eleven vials of blood to see if I'm
glucose intolerant turns out this is a
Beverly Hills rather you know
integrative medicine down there he's a
medical doctor you mean while the
[ __ ] I got one I'm going to a regular
Western doctor the [ __ ] nurse goes
well you got a abnormal blood an
abnormal blood sort of profile profile
and I'm like I called Brennan I go the
[ __ ] bro he does a dude let trust me
it's probably some [ __ ] I get in
there it's [ __ ] I don't find
anything I museum your zinc is off the
charts here take this
alright listen and all you do subscribe
it's gonna be five thousand dollars a
month you know for your health is it
worth them yeah I guess I left with a
bunch of [ __ ] a bunch of herbs I'm like
what I slowed them all out and by the
way my cholesterol was a little like I
may be a little high well I had eaten
right before that I eaten a pound of
bacon a bunch of eggs do your healthiest
[ __ ] your values so like five years you
never that's why when you tell me
suddenly you're like I mean so you're
you take your car and drop it off at a
mechanic and say something's wrong with
it and you think they're going to call
and say we didn't find anything
you know like there's nothing for us to
do we'll hold your car here until you
come to be like oh the fan belt is
bottom the transmission in your spark
work of court and you know you Elsa date
like doctors make money off a lot of
times a lot of times they can do this
especially the Hollywood doctor's
Beverly Hills doctor I'm not saying I
love most doctors are great people I'm
not saying but there's a business to be
made where you you can play on people's
fears where you can there are lots of
tests you can do where people's lead or
their mercury always is higher and we
look when you're at like in Beverly
Hills like a lot and I'm not saying you
know that they're bad people a lot of
people in that area because then I'll
get to the point here but in that area
have so much money that is just like
that and I do thing man like I dropped
off my Bentley at the Bentley do in
Beverly Hills I'd to get the general
checkup
and they told me the price and I went
you know I'm from Aurora well I'm not
from Beverly Hills I mean what the [ __ ]
for an oil change
what does [ __ ] Lea's bro looks me
squinting I this white English you just
bro in Beverly Hills at a Bentley dealer
you think even when anyone gives a [ __ ]
what we charge for oil it was like you
listen a lot guys I went right back man
I got argued he goes you don't buy a
Bentley and worry about oil change so I
guess I just
you don't I don't even bet there's a guy
there's a guy who's famous I won't go in
but he's got famous clients who I happen
to know go there right and he's a kind
of a celebrity doctor my buddy goes
there his friend she's just really
pretty girl she was I don't go there
anymore and here's why because this dude
he works by the way I think he works
with his wife too and he goes he looks
at her and she's really odd they go out
he go takes her out for a health
consultant consultation and he looks and
he goes you need to start using your
sexual power to heal other people and he
was getting closer and closer dr. minyak
feels a little dry this guy and then the
guy makes a hard pass at her as in a
touching hard pass and she's like this
guy's a [ __ ] fraud right and then she
starts reading it up on it and she's
like this got any right either
it's reflect you gotta use all [ __ ]
actual power and rayul it called on if I
use those reflective
the culture that we live in now right
because we have this just influx of
tremendous amounts of data and what are
you going to do with this data
everyone's really obsessed with these
genetic testing you know I could tell
you we were likely to cause like they're
likely to God
what are you going to do about that
actual information you're going to die
by some freak accident yeah good chance
well here's our you the chain here are
you more than likely what's connect
here's with all the athletes that you
deal with do you see a lot of them
talking more because it's you know you
have your new podcast I need to have all
these I mean legit
I mean superstar guest athletes from
comedians I was on there way more famous
people than Brian I on there but that's
right but do you see them especially
because a lot of them are retired more
issues about they're more aware of
health and what they signed up for they
get Ray Lewis on right absolutely great
little apps on Monday again we're gonna
get we have Ray Lewis up with does ray
I'm always so I guess intrigued by does
ray think anything of brain trauma CT
you see a we're of it here so what's
interesting about athletes today is that
they have more information than ever
right I mean and at an earlier and an
earlier a not only that the problem is
you can go on the internet so if you if
you get the biggest mistake I made was
oh you have screaming cell I went on the
internet and looked at pictures right
bro that it will [ __ ] you up for hours
like this is what I have well they show
you the most extreme case they've been
left for five years right but I can read
but like what was my dick if you've
heard hit who's a great he goes man if I
knew the repercussion football I would
have never signed up for it there's a
lot of that sort of sentiment and I you
know I don't know what the exact
breakdown is but there's there are quite
a few players former players who feel
like you know what had I known what I
know now I wouldn't play but then on the
other side there are the players would
say you know what I still would have
done it because the friendships the
bonds the coming into being a man that's
the way that I did it that was the road
that I took already the majority of
Medina I think a majority of players
like like I still would have done it
made a ton of money had a lot of fun but
I grew as a person so when I played
football in college it wasn't about
football as much a would as a
is becoming a man a lot of guys don't
want to talked about it though
yeah a lot like a lot of fighters you
entertain the idea why be competence
lichte Don it and also this is what they
do
I mean do we want a country do you want
America without football well do you
want it do you want to raise a child and
say don't do anything where you might
bump your head yeah I mean why is the
NFL being singled out so much when
boxing MMA hockey with rocky aluminum a
we knew it and they go you know what the
fudge time for uh NFL Roger Goodell
tried to hide it I that would be the
argument the the counter-argument to
that is that when it's all good baby
right what do we we don't we have seen
any signs of it no one's like all right
we'll just keep running into each other
I just so when I play football is I'm 45
now and I played football in high school
and I was just you know tiny kid going
up against giant behemoth you know uh
Huskies go mate high schoolers but the
drills that you would do of the kiss
drill local movie local home of the kiss
role I mean he be arrested if you were
like what did you hear in true we used
to the kissed her this is whether all
diggin this drill it was it was lining
up and just going helmets a helmet with
the person across from another bang bang
he was like you gotta toughen up your
head until I drill yeah he was called
become till I was 40 we got golden I did
that for one [ __ ] JV season in
boarding school and I went this hurts my
head so much yeah I remember the only
thing I've ever quit in my life I said
to my father I'm quitting he goes what I
go I don't want to play football it's
too cold it's too cold in England I'm
not built for it I have no and I go I
quit and he was like but when you went
across like in high school getting
knocked out in seeing stars and I saw
the blue dollar package yeah it was like
a yeah look this is my badge of honor
you know like hey I did something where
I got knocked out or I blacked out or I
saw stars no one in the 80s we're saying
oh man we have put you in a concussion
protocol right no one was saying that
but it's me my point on concussions like
okay so now we all know about it but
it's not just an NFL issue it's an all
sport issue what about X Games I mean
the amount of force these athletes are
hitting their head on the ground or the
lip of a ramp I mean is far beyond what
a foot we kind of know that though
games like right if you're going to take
a motorcycle and do a 360 and land on
your head your there's going to be some
issues like with football I think the
thing is is you have little kids do it
like we have little kids doing that X
Game style and football you have little
kids wrong they're the X Games stuff is
I live in Park City now yeah I mean it's
a I think your tear Prime Brennan is
that it's good to have this information
and it's now that you and we've had
people like Matt Mitrione and guys who
are played pro football who said they
wouldn't let their kid as their brains
are developing they wouldn't let their
kids play Pop Warner they wouldn't let
their kids play tackle football until
they were 16 or whatever be good and so
the more pleasure they have by the night
in play it's too late I don't agree with
that
like if you're down the Levin play it's
16 you should just let them play
mm-hm well if you look at a lot of NFL
players here's here's the the big
message first of all you need to play a
different sport every season yeah like
all the great athlete us write our
multi-sport athletes you can't focus on
one sport whether it's football or
basketball or baseball even though
people say oh no I'm a now sexualize
today by year-round its specialized and
of course those kids that play all year
round are going to be awesome when
they're 13 but the question is is when
they're 19 or they are they are they
much better in baseball they're throwing
a ball since they were 5 all year round
like that's why you see this explosion
and Tommy John surgery yeah it's because
they're just doing it too much if you
look at football my argument is I don't
think football is going anywhere
personally I don't think like the league
is on a shitload I don't think it should
and I don't think it will because what's
going to happen is the talent pool that
they're drawing from mostly is not you
know people with private coaches and
it's it's really kids that say this is
my way out of where I am that's a large
percentage of services worth the squeeze
for them it is they're like well like
what else am I going to do am I going to
receive your bill like like a certain
way like it here's a closer look at that
point if you if you know the the risk of
football and let's say I'm this freak
athlete I'm like God well I could just
go play baseball not deal with any of
this or I could go do this sport and so
when you do the statistics on the towns
that they're growing that you know a
more underprivileged kid right even is
saying look which way am I going to get
out if
if football is the thing to do and
that's the spotlight you're going to
play football
did you see the it Sun vice Lance of
Iceland sports Sat my boy Sal did it and
it's this it's kind of near Dade County
in Florida you have the most percentage
of NFL players come out of there it's
just small little County and football it
when I say this is lots of religion it
is life and the guy who started it
he started this like peewee program and
you watch it I'm like the level football
those little kids are playing is insane
insane so let me tell you want to get
into some stories that I have from the
department so Johnny large guys call
brink of midnight yet hit that drops a
drop month on Monday May 15 I Brenda
Brenda and I have done it but you've had
some 41 people to date like Ray Lewis
you're going to kick it off with who I
know you're really close with Ray Lewis
and Rob Riggle and Marshawn Lynch and
you know dr. Drew and Diana Nyad I swim
from Cuba to Florida and Randy Couture
loved it
lots of I mean 41 I got here about the
woman who swims and I got to hear about
Ray Lewis
no Tony Hall no Rob Riggle is a story
that you and I when I was doing as you
shared a story about love Rob Riggle the
story time at Rob Riggle is the most
fascinating one you will let's get into
the I've got a lot of fascinating story
sir
so the podcast is called the brink of
midnight podcast with John Brenkus where
we explore the moments when everything
changes at midnight did that staple so
if you say brink and midnight right it's
right before the carriage turns into a
pumpkin it's like life is going to go
one way or the other at midnight there
are these events that happen in life
where your life was trucking right along
and then everything changed from that
point forward for me was meeting my wife
on a plane sat next to her on a plane in
Denver we fell instantly in love love at
first sight turns out that we live two
blocks away from each other on the same
street in front you called me I remember
that's crazy
I went to your house directly from the
airport yeah I walked like this I just
met literally literally I just met the
girl I'm going to marry Jesus I'm in
love and it's over
game over I went bro you're a cyborg
what are you talking about how changed
your love life though but not no changed
oh she
every thrilling so yeah that was 14
years ago it changed the trajectory of
not only my personal life of my
professional life yeah just the the
energy that all the sudden was bestowed
upon me because of this connection that
I made with Lizzy my wife changed
everything it literally from decision
making in business of like should I do
this do that now I had a partner who is
fortunately much smarter than [ __ ]
much better latter she went Harvard and
Princeton
she got a graduate degree your Harvard
from Princeton undergrad Princeton
graduate gradual graduating for Harvard
Harvard these three languages in Cuba
marathons
she has three languages and she's she
got her Hana today her you answerin
singer and brains just come out to q9
yes she's really pretty and and super
athletic insane and Shane can sing we
had n we as well the brink of midnight
comes from us not only meaning but also
realizing wow we can make music together
so we wrote a Christmas song on a total
total flute I was just playing guitar
teaching myself ProTools wrote a song
she walks by is singing a tune over and
like where did this come from
she said I was classically trained in
the Long Beach Opera Company I told you
this how many times like what yeah so we
start so we start writing songs together
we put out a Christmas song it didn't
end up charting it literally was number
30 on the charges like Madonna Bruce
Springsteen Lizzy and John breakage
literally Bing a god on like oh my god
said to me and I was like who's singing
evil my wife ago she's singing she says
like Natalie Merman I'm like oh my god
so we warmed up she's a badass
she's a high-performing batter Lizzie is
a badass and she's really the really the
brains behind brink of midnight of
saying look we're gonna make a band and
we're gonna have a podcast that's
talking about these moments in
everyone's life where things change so
we were talking about football let me be
a great football story so Santonio
Holmes is it was one of her is one of
our guests
Santonio Holmes grew up in the third
poorest County in Florida and when he
was 11 years old he had five brothers
and sisters all from different fathers
and he was essentially
the patriarch of the family he was Ray
these kids and he said you know what
when he was 11 to bid I cannot achieve
greatness if I'm a dad at 11 so we went
to his grandmother and said there is
greatness inside of me that I need to
tap into but I won't if I'm a father
she said you come to church with me you
follow the way I got your back
and he said that moment when I was 11
changed the course of my life and he
said the catch in the Super Bowl that's
just a culmination of everything from
the point that I was 11 because I could
have gotten ready for that moment his
whole life
right he's like that he's like that that
doesn't even he's like that doesn't make
my list of things that changed my life
because that's just something I did I'm
good I was supposed to do like I was
supposed to catch that ball but I could
have gone down bad roads where I was
growing up but I didn't because of my
grandmother on that one day that County
and because of his success and others
this tiny little place tiny little place
under 20,000 people tiny little place to
spawn 35 NFL perps I stopped talking
about it's great it's constant actually
your first was the muck and it's when
you listen to it when you listen to the
full podcast and hear his entire story
you just can't help and say there are
moments in everyone's life where it's
this way or that way and if he hadn't
gone on that day on that time to his
grant he's like who knows where I would
be
who knows and it's amazing how everybody
has that story everybody has what about
Ray Lewis he's gonna so yeah Ray Lewis
first of all rain I I cannot tell you
the connect the instant connection we
had when I met him the first time which
was season two of sports science when I
met him he just we just immediately
clicked and he is so incredibly
authentic and I'm telling you he's here
doing God's work the brain Lewis is one
of the most inspirational people I have
ever met
I've heard that he is so he was telling
me and part of the story in the podcast
that airs on Monday is little I just got
the phone with him it's like literally
the Ray Lewis that nobody knew before
you knew Ray Lewis
these are the moments that actually
shake him he's like winning a Super Bowl
twice and being MVP and all that that
doesn't make my list of the moments that
changed my life he one of the key
moments he was 14 years old and he had
he was his father was gone and it was
just he had a single mother and his
mother had a boyfriend who was not
treating her well and Ray said gimme a
deck of cards and got a deck of cards
for his mom went into his room and
literally for six months to a year he
would throw down a card and it would be
a jack and he would do ten push-ups
throw down another card it would be a
four he do four sit-ups he said I would
do thousands of push-ups and sit-ups
every day just to become strong enough
to make sure that I was big enough and
intimidating enough to get that guy out
of my house I meant how long does today
like two weeks yeah yeah what's that
grown man yeah you wore a tedious prior
bit it is amazing and when you when you
tap into these moments he's like that's
where I took my life and my mom's life
into our own hand your own control yeah
I didn't sit back and allow myself to be
a victim I said you know what I can do
something about this what can I do as a
14 year old kid he's like and I wasn't a
big kid then he's like I had to figure
out a way to make sure that I was able
to protect he's always wondered about
him I would watch his intensity and how
he would get ready for games and how he
would talk to the team and there was
like I don't know too many people that
are more built I would say like you're
built for war like built for battle like
built for like his mentality his ability
to keep that intense was his passion it
was his passion up right soon oh yeah
and because athletically like he's not
he wasn't the fastest guy who wasn't the
biggest your fastest mm-hmm right and
he's hashed arguably the greatest
defender of all time
and his passion focus and energy
leadership he could lead man to battle
yeah he could bring greatness out of
people including himself and his
expectation for greatness was he really
looks at the world of you need to
she've greatness by seeing it doing it
wanting it practicing it in every facet
of your life
not just football like that's not just
that's not in every aspect into every
aspect you said you need to practice
greatness it'd be great and it's it's
such an honor to not only met him but
become good friends with them did you
talk about his relationship with shin
shark when Shannon Sharpe came to the
Baltimore Ravens you know what we didn't
get into the professional playing days
because those weren't the moments that
changed his life yeah
so our podcast I got a complicated
relationship no not at all no no no yeah
so shaven sharp you know everyone knows
shamsher ball star tight end you know
he's a hall-of-famer now but he was a
guy who kind he set the pace for the
Denver Broncos and then when he got to
bulkier he was got to set the pace and
showed Ray Lewis had reading these guys
how to like really tune it in and focus
so he would get to practice early he'd
get he was in the weight room early who
takes those guys to a workout just crazy
stuff coming out Ray Lewis said yeah
read and then his diet was the biggest
thing just before he got through their
diets were kind of loosey-goosey and you
know it isn't it fell shin sharp doesn't
do that he had meals and he said ray
Loewy said he went over his house he's
like dunamis they're about to do a
workout because I'm starving and Chan's
like do I got you man we I get them
heels down there he's like cool he says
go down there it's a plate and it's a
chicken breast and three things of
broccoli and like I guess like a sweet
potato right and Ed's like arrays like
what but how is this he's like that's
how we eaten it like you don't eat for
pleasure anymore
you eat to fuel your body and be the
best football player yes yeah he's like
oh hell no wow Jin just took you know
that mentality into another you talk
about the lead elite and he takes the
whole nother lemon yeah so right I mean
Ray is is kicking us off and you know
we're following it up with Rob Riggle on
Thursday we're releasing every Monday
and Thursday dude can you give us a
you're talking about robbery I already
love the guy I already do any satellite
Live alum I love I forgot he was on
there right because he was only on for
one young bald even so I mean I won't
read the book documentaries everything
he was also a man had a met how to be
Latin Lover he's always funny and ever
since he's funny and everything and he's
amazing can you get fluency but I'll
give you an obvious story so I'll give
you a little insight in the story it's
it's such an inspirational guiding so
genuine he in he learned to fly when he
was 19 and his grandfather taught him to
fly and he essentially got into flying
in the military and he was three years
into the military into flying and his
buddy calls him from Chicago and said
dude remember what a goofball you were
in college and you were just kind of
making stuff up on the fly he's like
people are it's called improv it has a
name he's like you should totally do
this you people are making money and
he's like wow and he went down to the
beach and he thought to himself and he
said what am I going to do I'm in flight
school right now I'm in three years if I
have to stay another five and that's
eight years that's your minimum and then
you have to spend another nine to get
full retirement and that's 17 he's like
wow I didn't realize that they had me
for like 20 years high slides anyway
he's I can't believe like what am I
going to do and not giving away the
entire story he literally wrote down an
affirmation that said I'm going to be on
Saturday Night Live and ten years almost
to the day it came true and the journey
that he had to go through to wind up
having that happen he said not moment on
the beach where I wrote down my
intention had a vision knew nobody in
the industry had never done anything in
comedy was just he was just in the
middle he's like I was a patriot how it
starts over in my country how crazy it's
crazy not it's not and if these stories
are so in-depth and they're amazing
there's something that everybody can
relate to I mean both of you were on the
podcast and the you know the moment
those moments a lot of times when I'm
finding out with these moments of change
everyone's lives is sometimes they're
aware and sometimes it's evolutionary
it's like wow I made I had this this
experience and at the time I thought it
was awful but it turns out it was the
best thing that happened to me because
if that didn't happen
that I never would have wound up where I
was yeah it was anyone on all the people
you've had to talk about how they
broiled like screwed up and it led him
to everyone here's a great story
so Randy Couture so we all know Randy
Randy is just an amazing guy Captain
America Captain America now what's
interesting is that without giving away
the entire story is that he was on the
trajectory he had a goal of making the
US Olympic Trials for Ruslan the goblets
is that was his goal you know grew up
with single mom and was like wrestling
is that's going to be the thing that I'm
gravitating toward and that's my goal
and he was well on his way to going that
direction and he got his girlfriend
pregnant and he had to make a decision
do I continue down the wrestling road or
do I give that up and get a job to
provide for my family because Russell
makes zero don't make zero dollars right
so he ended up saying you know what I'm
gonna go get something steady and make
money and he ended up to a new military
and he said alright I'm I'm out of the
ride and I use the military yeah yeah
and he said his deaths happen in America
well that's not that's not why you
called funny cat was part well part of
the Remillard long story short is over
two years after he was stationed in
Germany miss Olivia Maria he was in the
honors learner he was in there he went
over to Germany and they had a wrestling
tournament that he ended up entering and
winning without it wasn't like he like
was focusing on this and training in
winning and by winning it he got
automatic entry into the US Olympic
Trials for wrestling health he what he
said I was like this far away from it
and I went this direction all the way
around the block I was like in a time I
thought it was this oh my god I just got
my girlfriend pregnant said but without
that who knows what would have happened
can't even ask for him it was amazing
it's this the way that life and fate in
the universe and the energy and how
everything works regardless of your
religious belief somehow things come
together when you're aware well having
momentum like I just like sometimes I
think taking action regardless lead you
into something like I mean you know you
know what I'm saying like like I
remember watching I would always watch
like in any group you're in and you're
I'm sure starting to see this in
stand-up but acting stand up for
whatever anything you do I'm starting
fighting when you start to get good at
something you will see that the majority
of people create their own stagnant pond
what they'll do is they'll form their
own community where they don't have to
really hold each other accountable right
all the same way yeah right yeah so
that's why I was just talking about you
Stevie yesterday because he said you did
such a good job you know he said you
know you held their attention for two
hours you know and I was I got super
jealous and I insulted you but the thing
is this no but but I I'm bit I never had
any doubt that you would do well because
you know Brendan's doing stand-up now I
know but he's not just doing stand-up
he's created his own touring business
he's selling out on the roads going to
Australia with the big brown breakdown I
think it's [ __ ] I think is really
special and I'm and I'm still outraged
by it right I don't support it but
here's the thing here the thing and also
he's changed he owes his fame had a dick
it's not as respectful easy he does not
be advice anymore right you know what
[ __ ] let him fly bro he was a roadie
well yeah I'm happy not going on a cool
run no but I'm happy for you don't see
please please fly away on your own I
shoulda the National even though your
wings you think they're big enough to
fight a [ __ ] Australia good luck over
those I think you know his line they
plan first class first class
this [ __ ] all [ __ ] was
selling out on the road but but the
point is that I was saying to my wife in
the John I said well when Brendan told
me that could have took him a while to
admit to himself what he really wanted I
was like III had been saying they want
to go I have no doubt this [ __ ]
going to succeed and you know by the
time he's 40 you're going to be seeing
you know in my opinion probably a really
good headlining comic with specials
under his belt which I know as part of
his dream there's no doubt and the
reason is because he never stops [ __ ]
moving
and I know also that when guess in that
stagnant pond which he did with fighting
and now withstand it when you see that
you know what fuels them what few of
them is gone hey these people are moving
I'm just going to work harder now and I
think that's very important that's a
true line with a lot of successful
people is it you just keep taking action
what are you right I mean just keep
moving forward you know there what's
interesting is you know one of the
quotes for the podcast we have is you
know life presents a brick wall and some
people either just stop and look up and
say wow that's a big wall and other
people like you know what I don't know
how long this wall is but I'm gonna get
a roundish if I'm gonna go under it I'm
gonna go over it I'm gonna put my hand
in my friend way and I'm just gonna go
do it right I'm gonna know Bryan Callen
that he's not that funny
early now he's eglee right I'm going to
the store I have a set tonight nothing
[ __ ] really on a Tuesday Hey Dude
want to hang out no I'm going to do
psycho and Donna what are you doing last
night I gotta tell you what are you up
to and I'm like oh I'm having dinner
with my wife you want to join no Java
period no period got a set at the store
yeah we're young yeah why'd you come hey
do you do anyway do you feel like a lot
of people in these stories
do they chalk it up to religion a lot
I've been saying I wish I don't know
what you stand on this weed on dinner
but I would find it so interesting and
almost I'm jealous of the guys who chalk
up the certain moments to religion right
well the so I was born and raised
Catholic and I but I didn't go to
Catholic school and what was hammered
into me from a very young age is there
is no one right religion like you're a
religion for you as a way to relate to
the universe and however that is whether
or not you're agnostic or an atheist or
whether or not you're a Buddhist you're
you're viewing the world in a particular
way but we all have this common goal of
genuinely perpetuating love and that
that is genuinely our purpose whether or
not it's due having children or being
kind whatever it is giving back to
others we're perpetuating love now the
commonality in all of these stories is
everybody does relate to the universe
one way or
the other regardless of their religious
belief they have a view in that view
does effect okay am i moving forward or
not what I'm finding is that the people
that are high achievers are also big
believers they're believers in I'm not
going to fall off the cliff I'm going to
take the step and there's going to be
something underneath us there's a higher
being just because the way they look at
the universe some people like Diana Nyad
great example she's an atheist she's the
only person to swim from Cuba to Florida
and you want to know what age she had
her big brink of midnight moment where
everything changed in her life when she
was 60 60 60 and she has been failed
four times swimming from Cuba to Florida
you know what happened her didn't she
get stung by [ __ ] crazy I always hear
just everything you know her Mia and
jellyfish and weather and dehydration
the only person ever swim that whole
thing yeah no matter than that or with a
bit without it no with no shark cage no
shark cage no not she not she with one
c3 but you not do it once and people
like Oh bull should you go to met no
that happened no did she took it away no
she never made that up you did make that
no never I mean I think there was
somebody who did that who was right and
they had a draft thing they had Hebrew
address that's [ __ ]
yeah if boat was creating a draft you
absolutely delicious
she failed four times and the last time
she did she was in her 30s she took 30
years off of swimming too long that's a
long break everybody that's a break
that's a woody Brett you're not sore
anymore right so she and she when she
was 60 was reading a poem went that the
essence of the poem was saying what did
you do with your beautiful life what did
you do with the opportunity you've been
given just one opportunity that you've
been given she was 60 in her car and she
said ah I've never made it to Florida
from Cuba swimming I've got to do it
after taking 30 years off she's like
that was the moment that changed but
she's like and now she has the luggage
she's like I had the luxury of time of
looking back in my entire life when you
hear the other moment that you would
think oh yeah being sexually abused at a
really young age yeah that would be
a moment that would change your life so
yeah that's the might it changed my life
for sure big moment but that's not the
big big one yeah that didn't happen in
so long because she knows a bunch of
signs no no which she had tried no well
what what else our inner thigh and some
people just don't have inspiration until
it comes out of nowhere
yeah what's alrighty entry she was
already a rock star in the endurance
circuit and engagement all shoes mic to
music right she was already but she was
already a star in that scene in that she
was going to do speaking engagements and
motivational things of hey don't give up
and don't try and she decides she ends
up completing the swim from Cuba to
Florida when she's 63 I mean like what
he would not crazy when you're sick home
Undertaker I forget the exact time it
was 100 and it's like 110 miles to
summon on snow swimming not how about
hey by the way how about walk 110 miles
see how long I'm at now do you want to
know what's amazing about this you know
what her new causes her new cause she's
like distance swimming is inaccessible I
mean not everybody can just go out and
you know try to swim ten miles from it
five miles right it's just too
time-consuming to whoever her new cause
is to get people to walk she's like how
about we just get everybody walking
everyday exciting but I farm exercise
and that's her new mission so she
literally is created created her own
movement and they're having walks and
they're going to do giant walks all over
the country it's really inspirational
they just walk just walk walk school you
see uh I think okay I think Kevin Hart
uses platform you know he does you know
mostly clinical torrent ever and he you
know came out with Nike he's teamed up
with Nike has his own shoe any city goes
into they do a huge marathon yeah it's
like run with Kevin Hart and you know
it's like thousands of people running
for Kevin Hart a manatee and it's like
get out and move I mean but really the
key to health is just do something every
day yeah
just whether it's why they say all the
blue zones they all garden they all work
outside with their hands low pace
division or saying like active lifestyle
yeah like they they all do something
typically most of them have a garden
which is weird yeah but but the point is
that they're digging your letter Z
they're moving your movie
and something to think about the way
that that our society has sort of molded
the workplace right I mean it's like a
cubicle and a chair and sitting typing
crouched and screen right here like it's
not good for us as a physical form
well type 2 diabetes is up I was going
to talk about some dropping also doesn't
matter but the type 2 diabetes is up
seven hundred percent Jesus because
since 1960 not not alcohol-related fatty
liver disease which is was only what
alcoholics had is now prevalent in
children in epidemic proportions I mean
Americans and people in Western
countries have it in the tens of
millions where people are having
metabolic diseases like this all because
what's fascinating is samurais did an
amazing podcast on this with Gary Taubes
we cannot agree on how to eat but we
know one thing there's a lot of money
and sugar and a lot of money in sort of
simple carbohydrates that's food you
know and Isis but that's what season but
that's also what's affordable
well actually the whole focus also
actually though in fact if you look at
Michael Pollan stuff that's not what's a
portable so when you if you need simple
foods right carrots a sweet potato a
broccoli an apple that's on the deal so
you can't make money off that it's not a
meal though what do you mean it's not a
meal like apples here it's no I'm saying
so let me let me break it down so a
piece chicken or you know two eggs an
apple and a sweet potato let's just for
like just for argument's sake there's
not a lot of money in that when you when
you sell foods that way so the food
industry here makes a lot of money by
combining a lot of stuff so they'll face
yogurt low-fat you over without to sugar
and it's got fruit anything to agree
with yeah right so that when you do that
that what happens is the way you sell
things with low-fat if you've got to put
a lot of sugar because they won't taste
good
yeah and so so much it's cheaper way to
do that mass-produce it do I know it's
interesting is you know Herschel Walker
oh yeah you know he ate one meal a day
and still eats one meal with he's a
genetic freak just the problem these
guys of this affectionate but we might
get attacked like I get some bad at all
his I didn't break he does hit with OPEC
sir sizes such a religion he does a
million push-ups a day by heroes is that
when I'm
Veta mmm eh it was 44 beating the [ __ ] I
died 49 I think yeah he was one of the
middle the fungus brings the ball bring
him up at his age now take a look at his
body because it's ridiculous it what is
amazing about him is that look he never
lifted away did push-ups and sit-ups
genuinely which is the theory of yoga
right like you have all the weight you
need and everything to get all the
strength that you need you know he
doesn't eat that much I mean and he said
and when I met him I'm like this so why
do you only won one time today he just
said I just don't need that much food
and you're but what's amazing about your
body is how it adapts to whatever it is
that you're putting into it
yeah the question is when you start
putting stuff into it that it can't
overcome that'd be him it but that's
that's Herschel Walker now again we have
to be careful when you take these
extreme athletes these these complete
freaks
you probably Bryan Callen probably
wouldn't follow that protocol
necessarily they're probably things to
learn from a guy like that but he's
already said to dinner you know this so
I agree you but you can just take aways
you can do from it like you know I used
to when growing up my family still Nonie
better it's like breakfast the most
important meal you know sugars oatmeal
brown sugar then you got out of snack
now you need lunch and you're gonna have
a big dinner eat your potatoes you need
your fat your cheese and all that stuff
we can to use all right sodas alright
and then you know as you get older get
more educated you know now I'm around
two meals a day like I fast all morn I
don't eat two one if you had done it to
me in high school I would have been like
you're crazy right my body you know it
takes a while for it to that if you were
conditioned three three meals a day
breakfast the biggest one the food
pyramid which is complete [ __ ] but
there's if it's just more of educating
people now I'm not saying eat once a day
and you end up like your Walker right
yeah how we got more shredded from 50
from 21 to 15 so think about this think
about this in terms of what you are
conditioning your body for Aaron and I
did this I've done this recently I just
gave up processed food so in my process
I mean like you like clearly process
Parker and then it's something yeah
stuff that's just you look at it you're
like I don't know if it's gonna come out
of me really easily I can issue momaday
device people go what is that excited to
something like fast-food cheeseburgers
I'd read in muffins and stuff that you
look at and I in my brain I go I don't
know if it's going to get out of me I'm
not I'm not sure how long it's gonna
take me to process this like that's that
that's my standard what's amazing is
when you look at the the meals that
you're actually being served in the size
of the portions and things that are in
it if you just say to yourself I mean
eat half of that I'm just going to eat
half so tough to do some have I know but
if you were only given that if you go to
Europe and go to Italy right they're not
giving you giant portions so I would
trim nice nice measured portions if you
say to yourself I'm only going to eat
half that meal III go to a restaurant I
literally don't order because I'm like
I'm going to eat leftovers because
nobody's going to finish all their meal
yeah so I'm going to eat might whatever
my kids donate I'm all eat that is going
to be fine it's amazing how little you
actually need to eat to stay helping and
it don't know how you're eating the
right stuff if you don't know a lot much
right you don't eat actually a lot which
is amazing for a guy your size and your
giant you much bigger than I am but you
don't consume what he had to demand
though it's a struggle every day right
but you you seem to have a pretty good
handle on because you had to kind of
learn about it right yeah I just I'd be
curious with all these people you've
interviewed how many of them talking
about diets and stuff because let's be
real here you're interviewing the 1% of
1% like Ray Lewis alright alright what's
your routine ray it's gonna be [ __ ]
tough for most people to relate to it
yes six year old swimmer okay I get it
you're 60 you can swim your balls off we
all wait a coding tough so I think
regular people like alright well so I'm
not getting into any of the like diet or
any of sort of like the routine because
I'm looking for the moments the change
should be a moment it could be a moment
but it's it might have main answer how
they learn exactly it did like if you
don't know but if this might be too soon
but if you have big black on from Rob &
big and right he's like the moment for
me is when I change my diet Oh doesn't
have a heart attack yeah I just died
shot a big black love that guy but I'm
saying that that could been a huge
moment for him it could have been a
change to be 200 pounds his moment could
have been dropping the goddamn Korean
barbecue
in this huge moment right when you look
at what are those moments in life where
everything changed diet certainly could
be one of them probably real own
probably rare right that's probably not
because there was something that led up
to it science that got you to change
your diet in the furtive rice I said
something that kind of as an example in
my own life you know I was the meathead
in the gym when I was 27 years old so I
was you know I was bench pressing
decline in flight just crazy weight I
looked like you know I look like a
pyramid I mean being awesome John I was
I was like I was a total lie Condon
awesome oh yeah I had like little skinny
legs but I could lift a ton of weight
when I was 27 but I then said to myself
you know what I wonder if I can run a
mile
I'm just curious and I tried to run a
mile I couldn't I weighed 198 town
didn't I buddy I was like almost at 200
pounds I'm like oh my god I'm almost 200
pounds I'm really strong why you don't
know John Johnson an extremist like he's
an extremely are you I gave Michelle
another I gave him a shake - you did
this guy was on the national speed
skating team and he's a nutritionist and
he's really smart in this shake was
really awesome it was like almond butter
you put like you know maybe half a
banana you put some green powder you put
some protein powder was a good shake and
I say I prescribed it to John's I should
do this thing works for me man yeah I
get to try this out and he goes he comes
me because I'm getting gas a lot of gas
ago well why cuz what are you putting in
it he goes no just what you told me I go
well how much he's drinking knowing him
and he goes well I put three bananas and
I say Papa Charles just literally
literally an entire gallon sitting down
I was like hey Kerry J yeah how about
one [ __ ] glass eunuch so I do think
Lizzie my wife hers to me is just one
speed I'm either on or all evil as
exhibited health when I was almost 200
pounds was 198 I never got to 200 I said
I literally said no more lifting ever
I'm gonna what I'm going to do is I'm
going to break the five minute mile and
I was 27 I was I'm gonna I'm gonna break
the five in a mile because I can't
complete a mile and in high school when
I ran the mile I never broke five
minutes I'm so lame and I'm like god I'm
going to do it I track
my old high school track coach and said
where I'm gonna train to break five in a
mile just because I lost 47 pounds and
ran a 455 yes hi John that's a cute like
and I was it I was with him when he was
training for a triathlon and we were
shooting in England and we was we were
shooting this show for Discovery sports
it was so like we would wake up early
and they would have to write the script
they would really write it and I would
edit it and we would do it we have to
shoot we have to interview people it was
a long long day John had a cold John
looks like that and John I've never seen
anybody and to this day the only person
that competes is during fact I have
never seen anybody who needs less sleep
I've never really ate time here also
that food I'm talking about
I saw it run over with my own money well
I'm talking about he would go to bed at
12:00 be up at 4:00 and and he had a
cold and I go what are you doing you
don't don't run a day because I will run
today I will I will run 12 miles today
and he would run and he would so we'd be
shooting and he would wake up way too
early run 12 miles or whatever - and
then still kill so you know to that
point done five Ironman triathlons I did
the Leadville 100 mile bike race I swam
from Hermosa Beach Pier to Santa Monica
mother was riding mile right white
everywhere you know it's exactly it was
like I do a lot of extreme stuff now get
this so when my wife when Lizzie and I
mean I'm doing the Ironman in Kona for
the show and I'm I'm so I'm doing the
Ironman in Kona it's the Superbowl of
triathlons and oh my god I'm doing it
I'm surviving and Lizzie decides you
know what I think I want to give that a
go I think I want to do it and in the
back of my mind I'm like I don't think
you understand what you're getting
yourself into so Lizzie as a mom of two
decides to start to Train and I start
giving her the workouts for running she
was never a runner she didn't know how
to swim
she was never a cyclist [ __ ] so she
decides you know what
I'm gonna become I'm gonna run and I'm
gonna give me some workouts so she knew
nothing about it so I gave her all the
workouts of how to break a 5 minute mile
that was that my high school coach had
given me when I did it she keeps coming
home from the gym she's like okay I did
that what next I'm like what what are
you talking about she's a hot - hot
- so that calabasas 10k well which she
ran she runs it the first time she runs
it she sets the course record Jesus
Chris he's just like what like what
would an x-men yeah he been caged in
gray she rents a 125 half marathon as
one of her first just like endurance
she's like oh yeah I'll run out half
she's a 125 we entered the same Ironman
Triathlon she can't she really is not an
amazing swimmer she's an average swimmer
let's run a tough spot every time
yeah well it's the hardest part for her
yeah she is so much faster than everyone
else in the run each event that we've
done she just runs by and hits me right
in the butt and she's like later she'll
finish an hour ahead of me why Rose me I
feel really hands I be told she's not
five one she's five feet tall by the way
she's five feet she'll say well I drove
fast well I get hope take a warm hand er
oh yeah no disrespect you never like Sun
something I got a wrong yeah yeah ever
well are you think about running a
marathon yeah I want to yeah I've run my
daily living around 14 60 miles a week
yeah we're doing I'm 240 pounds that's a
lie it's a it's pretty amazing then I
run the San Marcos stairs I usually do
I'll do like four miles a day and then
I'll run Sarah Mike stairs back to bed
Lizzie can training because she's
trained a bunch of people in marathon
she has her own you know coaching
business that she like look she's such a
good athlete and gone through so much
she's like here's here's a plan she'll
uh my collegiate environment
you want to do the Ironman so um I mean
both she and I I can here's your workout
regimen for eh and interesting it's an
interesting experience for them to do
you know you made somebody like the
swimming wouldn't be a problem
I love swimming yeah you just got to do
it for me it'd be fun time to admit to
it would stand up yeah there's a
difference so doing so I've done five of
them
I really enjoyed like one of them
because the other there is there's a big
difference between finishing and
enjoying finishing yeah there's a huge
because why because it is so grueling
it's just such a if you're not really in
awesome shape which for it is really
like for two or three of the father did
in great shape but it's a long day and
you're like oh my god I'm pushing
through this and when you cross the
finish line like I've already done it
three times like why did I do that how
do you feel how do you feel the next day
or that way I mean you obviously you're
really you're really deeply but it
really depends on each athlete like for
me when I'm not in that great of shape
and you're finishing it you're pretty
wiped out for people who do this all the
time don't you know you can just keep
going and going and going it's not like
this monumental thing that affects you
for people who are really good I heard
campaigns you know campaigns is he's
alchemists on runner but best hunter in
the world just a man's man and he was
talking about there's a race that he
wants to do that only like 14 people
have ever completed there's no map cuz
ya think yeah and you run like through
the woods at night and I forget how many
miles create crazy yeah it's a crazy
race
it's like 150 something miles but he
said he ran like 50 got to a point
anyone to take a nap he took a nap and
he said he's so far ahead of everyone
and so he fell asleep I don't know for
like 40 minutes woke back up started
running sheet 24 hours gotta go and he
said he got the finish line he figured
the Afeni he's fourth he's like what the
[ __ ] found out those other guys aren't
sleeping runners do that yeah they're
running for hours they brothers yeah
they run today what yeah you get a run
through no matters nothing you have gray
just got to figure it out it's pretty
nothing run through the night you talk
to campaigns out you know yeah I'm
really glad I know he runs that devil
one would do the you know they start the
lowest point jump on it go all the way
through the peaks or about 200 degrees
yeah yeah I would get into what's
interesting about the Ironman is when I
did my first one it was in 1990 was 1997
and it wasn't nearly this big like
enterprises it is now let's kill me I
mean now what is it exactly how many
mono it's two point four mile swim 112
mile bike and 26.2 mile run here's a
great set of my first Ironman so when I
decide to do an Ironman I break the
five-minute mile my friend my best
friend ran the Marine Corps Marathon and
like all best friends do when he called
me all right
did it I said that's great how many
other people were in the race and
finished in didn't Oprah run a marathon
like and over I didn't do higher man
though right
oh no that's what I said I said Oprah
never did an Ironman I'm gonna do an
Ironman
what's an Ironman so I look it up and
I'm like oh man it's a 2.4 miles swim I
don't know how to swim but I guess I'll
figure it out - 112 mile bike I don't
know how to bike but I guess I'll have
to go buy one oh and a 26.2 mile run
I've never run more than a 5k so but all
right I guess I'll give that a try so I
just decide to do it just to one-up my
friend yeah I like I'm gonna just one-up
you so I go to the pool and I literally
get the little kitty you know a swim
instructor and I'm like can you teach me
how to swim because do not know I didn't
I only knew how to not drown I didn't
know how to stroke effect and breathe or
anything so cut - so I trained by myself
with you know the dead of winter in
Virginia ratified you see it's a
horrible winter it's freezing and I go
to New Zealand on my own I do an Ironman
I'm in in New Zealand and there's a fun
swim that happens two days before the
race and it was a two-mile open water
swim and my buddy called me and said you
should do you should try swimming in the
open water because there's not a wall or
any Lane cookies like it's harder than
you think so I said okay so ice when I
get in the water and they're only about
a hundred people doing this fun swim
it's not even part of the event it's
just like a a weld-on swim I thought I
was literally going to drown his and I'm
swimming I'm only you know 1/4 mile into
this and I'm like oh my god this is the
worst obituary ever yeah van is one of
them it's also in grave for weeks before
the kitty instructor right behind water
like a guy like this rocks you guys
gonna do a dry like that no no that's a
good quarter Sokka yeah tonight yeah
yeah no everyone else is moving Gaga oh
yeah and that's that it is literally the
oceans cause Fang but it's not like oh
my god get them people get there like
you will see John that's exact I'm not
down that's right but nobody
he would even ask that because you
didn't have to sign up for the event
it's a it's the equivalent of a fun run
and the headline is John missing John no
no we found the body John dies in water
after thinking he was qualified to swim
that's crazy [ __ ] right with a with a
kid instructor back at it all this John
God solicit so I do that swim I swim the
two miles in one hour was a half hour a
lot and half hour per mile which isn't
horrible but I was the whole I was just
thinking to myself this is this is awful
I'm gonna die in this terrible so I go
seek out there's an instructor that's
there that's having a clinic who is a
former Olympian and I just go up to the
guy I'm like listen the race is in two
days
I don't know how to swim evidently like
I need a clinic this guy just literally
spend in the clinic hour with me he
teaches me catch up swimming it which is
just you know making sure that you're
not dropping your hand too early so he
teaches me to catch up swim day the race
comes it's two point four miles so it's
almost a half mile further I just I'm
scared out of my mind there eleven
hundred people in the race I gun goes
off I finished two point four miles in
59 minutes she almost a half mile
further and I'm in the top 10% of the
whole race Jesus and I had never gone
that distant performance drag never it
was it was this just I literally just
focus on exactly what this Olympian told
me well I said that's all I said
I just don't drop your hand don't drop
your hand and keep going - keep going -
it was a tiny little detail of like
you're working too hard you're working
against you have to have a conversation
with the water you got to reveal the way
yours with conserve your energy he was
and so I'm like oh my god I can't
believe it and as it turns out I'm
actually a decent swimmer I'm like wow
so I like that Roger Bannister story
about how all these physiologist said
it's impossible to break four-minute
mile now like it's not - how long does a
human man this is 1961 or something I
didn't see Hussain Bolton no but no
camera no photo for the mile democratize
right so grab the data just didn't see
like the type of athletes that were to
be around
well can envision that well miles a
little bit different but so so what was
the point I make is that the guy runs it
he shatters everybody my god it's
humanly possible
that same year five other guys did it
forty-seven days later forty-seven is
when we can conceive of some Bannister
broke it then 47 days later someone else
breaks it in the malady and the neck is
doing it literally the next 10 years 300
people break it yeah and if it's once
every 12 days it was like just something
crazy soon as people go oh [ __ ] someone
can do that I can definitely have that
and that and that goes to there is an
amazing theory of look maybe once
something happens it's in our collective
conscience right like we are what's
possible yeah like you know what we all
know as a species hey this is something
that we can do and it's not well not the
the crazy but I wrote a book called the
perfection point that was a New York
Times bestseller about what is the
theoretical limit of human performance
if everything were perfect if you had
the perfect human specimen in the
perfect conditions with the perfect gear
how fast could you run the honey would
you get on a mile so you got to read the
book but for I'll give you example
there's a Minotaur - hundred meter
hundred meters a critter Miller - is I
believe the ultimate record is eight
point nine nine that's the fat I just
possibly could run now you'll look up
and you describe the body type but
they're really instant bears the body
type here's the perfect condition is a
hussein bolt close to that body type it
is close to that body type you would say
okay this is sort of long short body
it's long legs long legs you have to
have you know obviously your stride
stride rate versus stride length ratio
needs to be exactly perfect you have to
be at the right elevation yet after I
choose you got to have the right
tailwind because if the tailwind has a
limit you have to have the right
reaction time because it doesn't count
if the reaction time is often if
everything we're perfect and we're lined
up and when people look at a graph and
actually say well you same both is such
an outlier if you actually look at the
graph and I have it in the book and the
perfection point Usain Bolt just put us
back on course because there is this
dark age in between Ben Johnson and when
Usain Bolt broke the record because
there is this dark period where the
world record was not being broken there
other mark like it was it took a while
for us to break it and we caught back up
to where we were supposed to be so
that's there are really I'm well I can
right yeah what is that the drugs ended
up changing is that straight in your
book when you say it's eight point nine
nine nine or whatever 500 is do you take
in the account with performance Anthony
Alex I presume that I assume that all
athletes are on drugs you had a really
good in the really good point on the in
the book about this you want to assume I
assume I assume everybody is on whatever
can maximize the human frame because
there's there is a limit to how strong
and big and fast you can actually get
because the frame can only support so
much so in the theory of the book I'm
saying whether it's through a PE D or
natural you arrive at the ultimate the
body could be so young with performs
right in it's a series out of it there's
a physics there's a to the big lemon
right because you can only get to be so
strong before the frame before if you
have 2,000 pounds over your head you're
trying to bench no matter how big and
strong you think you are it's going to
crush your frame cancel but was the
highest vertical leap that we've
recorded did you recur to like yet you
know when you look at the vertical leap
of the highest in history it's really
it's really kind of controversial
because the numbers are so exact I mean
they're not accurate if you look up
right now Michael Jordan 50 inch
vertical leaf you'll find people that
say oh Michael Jordan had a 50 inch
vertical leaf Michael Jordan's the
greatest basketball player to ever play
but he did not have a 50 inch runaway
Genesis right this way
we had we had a young healthy Dwight
Howard in the lab that set the record
for the highest touch of 12 12 feet six
inches
highest touch of anybody at all though
right he's like yeah he's like six 11
seven feet but but he's the perfect
combination when you hear people say oh
my buddy can grab a quarter off the back
of a backboard you're like not a NBA
backboard that's thirteen feet well I
grow tents apparently could do you have
footage of it that's my answer no yeah
that's all yeah that's all composure
where that's all playground that's all
playground they put a quarter on a
playground backboard and they grabbed it
off the top of that but not an NBA
backboard like if if Michael Jordan
couldn't do it LeBron can't do it right
Howard couldn't do it nobody so when you
say high as well you say high as
vertical and you see Dwight Howard who
it record in your stew
but he's seven foot tall I'm sure if you
had spud Webb in there yeah we know that
like my job Bobby has high
nobody's also [ __ ] time exactly it
depends on our to reorder it's your
power to weight ratio your fast twitch
muscle fibers depends how explosive you
it's like all those factors lined up so
it's a I mean I've been very fortunate
to have a front row seat to analyze the
world's greatest athletes the bids a big
commonality quite honestly in sort of
all this performance talk is our blood
there Brendan no big eyes I'm sorry no
that's where you're going no well you
know we're talking about this absolute
family show our you know let me make my
point yeah sorry war god sorry
it's they work hard they have vision and
they all have a moment in their life
where they went one way or the other
yeah there's no physical issue there is
a but listen that physical issue when
people say oh they're all genetic freaks
I can't stand that argument of people
saying well they're just your Herschel
Walker well he's just a genetic freak at
the elite level they're all genetic
correct they're all - you're on a level
playing field when they go yeah but that
one guy is blank what that one guy
worked harder stayed longer was smarter
played the game better they're not when
you took me cuz there's a there's a and
you know I'm not discrediting Herschel
Walker but there's a ton of guys who are
out there just built like Herschel
Walker who never did [ __ ] it's true
there are there's a ton of literally
chopped there it's a true who decided
not to risk any theater their comfort of
being in their spot also supported as
you know Court is elusive it's very
interesting because so you can have guys
guys who are amazing athletes I'm sure
Larry Byrd didn't have a high vertical
in a fast 40 and there are a lot of
things I'm sure he's very athletic way
more athletic people realize but at the
same time what made him great was these
sort of other mitigating circumstance
these other bird was also freaked out
you know instantly people do salt I'm
because Larry was white Larry was very
smart calculated but these black super
freak athlete no no labored is a
physically they are every when you when
you look at when you look at athletes
and you sort of say you know look at the
great the greatest of the great so look
at Gretzky like was he the biggest
strongest fastest now player on the kit
Messi need to look at Messi right that
you got this guy that's just little tiny
dude running around like it and that's
why it's very when people say who are
the who the advocates you've worked with
that impressed you the most like guys
who are my side like Isiah Thomas for
the Celtics oh my he's my size and he's
tearing it out sides would even bruised
he's literally factors not he's five
nine no he's a point Mizzou how do you
live in your view I Pistons nothing
about Brian Brian doesn't watch the NBA
cigar no he just got fifty three people
in Detroit Pistons right Isiah Thomas is
the starting point guard for the
developer who might think about that but
you know Isiah Thomas it's a point guard
from so god yeah so there's Isiah Thomas
okay and who's all retired or why I've
got men they're not Isiah Thomas the
pimps named them after I did night guys
who's the star in a pipe finish third
fourth MVP voting for the Boston Celtics
his sister's a stylin yeah yeah he
scored 53 points you tonight in okay I'm
freaked out like he's my son like my
size playing it's trees yeah right even
a little
he's a little short like Allen Iverson
yeah it's over anis yeah in that and
those are the people that are that
really impressing the most but even with
all that the idea of what makes someone
great I'm telling you that there's a
moment that happened whether or not it
was in Ray Lewis's life or Marshawn
Lynch's life where they had to go one
way or the other that that's the
commonality in your podcast you could
have gone one way or the other you think
about the fact that you are not somebody
who's you could have could you have kept
playing football could you have kept
fighting but you just sought you made it
like that moment happen where you're one
way or the other and your life is never
the share those moments that idea of
growth that idea of achieving greatness
is what the brink of midnight podcast is
about and that's what the common thread
is behind all high achievers and I think
everybody has those moments it depends
on how profound they are in their life
and how you're actually viewing them one
theory that I have or they didn't take
action and I want to see if you agree or
disagree at this I think these brink of
midnight moments that happen happening
cycles they can only happen at certain
points in your life and I use like if
you visualize a graph
in just a straight 45-degree line going
up that's your life of where you should
be and what you should be doing this is
where you the way you're supposed to go
but we don't live life in a straight
line we live it in a zigzag so we're
crossing that line and every time we
cross that line a moment could happen
things line up like you're ready for
change and then if you don't if it
doesn't happen you go keep going off and
then you come back and you cross it
again does that moment happen again for
it's over for in my case could like the
day that I met Lizzie if that had
happened when I wasn't crossing the line
and I was tremor over Here I am ready
for it it wouldn't I wouldn't would it
have been the same person Lizzie I keep
saying if we met five years ten years
earlier never would have gotten we never
would have been love at first sight
because I was a totally different person
yeah it's really interesting how
interesting you think about how it has
to all line up and how many factors you
have to be I'm used to seeing it when it
happens sometimes you don't see us
you'll be in the right frame of mind you
got to be ready for the opportunity well
and you have to have you might earn that
you might not have been in a place to
even talk to her maybe we were dating
someone else or maybe just I don't know
you know that success is funny to this
Daniel Kahneman won a Nobel Prize for
this this sort of studying like you know
why certain things happen and Thinking
Fast and Slow is his book and you know
you said that so much of when you look
at like they've done all these case
studies written all these books on
companies that do really well and is it
the corporate culture and stuff like
that well sometimes the company does
really well because what so many other
companies are not doing at the moment so
again it's timing like they happen to
get there first everything was aligned
the right way climbing visit VHS beta
like which one wins the war like like
it's the timing of hey these things that
happen does it all line up and which is
going to win and in your own life what's
the what's that version of VHS versus me
like which way are you actually going to
go and which which which emotion is
going to prevail at the time and I think
a lot of these brink of midnight moments
that happen there's also having the
courage to acknowledge you know what I
am going to go that way it's it's scary
to change things up it's scary whether
or not it's dictated to you
- and you get sick in some way and you
have to change course because you have
either your free will has been abandon
that point or if you say you know what
I'm by my own free will I'm changing
course yeah well let me ask you before
you save by my free will because you're
going to read 41 people of all the
people there moment yes right well how
how many of them took action out of
severe discomfort or desperation I would
say it's 50/50 that it's it's like what
was inspiration the idea I can do this
the other was just desperate
yeah just like look you know I give you
a really really good example of Ric
Bucher who's a phenomenal journalist
sports journalist he has his own show on
Sirius XM he's he's one of the most
famous sports journalists he was getting
out of college and he went to an Ivy
League and he kind of said you know what
um you know I'm kind of a big deal and
I'm gonna go over and take over New York
and he gets an interview with Esquire
magic I never felt better right he's
like he gets an interview with Esquire
magazine's like Esquire yeah I don't
know maybe I'll work for that I don't
know and he goes to the interview and he
doesn't get a callback and all of his
other friends are now working on Wall
Street and making tons of money and he
doesn't have a job yet and the only job
he can find is writing for a tiny little
paper in San Diego that's covering local
football and he's like oh my god
wait I what ya going on he's getting
paid nothing and he's writing stories
that no one is reading and he's in a
community where nobody cared he's like
what am i doing like I thought I was
going to take over the world he said if
it weren't for that if it weren't for me
being put in my place I never would have
wound up where I am because to this day
I do all of my own research I write all
of my own stories I have to look for
angles that are interesting that people
would actually care about because I
started writing about a topic that
nobody was reading and nobody cared so I
had to do it all myself and he said that
moment at the time it was just awful
he's like it was devastating to me
but it's what made me be able to follow
the road he gets where I feel like is
acting-wise him
I was so I go to theater school I'm
gonna be a great actor but am [ __ ]
gonna do this and now I'm like oh well
you know what my dad's not really happy
with me because he's paying my rent and
he's not really talking about and I have
to go get a job so I go get a job and
now I'm working as a temp at Goldman
Sachs and I'm doing I'm making copies
back in the day I'm making copies and
I'm running coffee more coffee
sure your coffee would you want for
lunch monk this down by the way I'm 20
like that's not a job for you
no dude I'm writing down I'm making
copies and I smell remember I smelled
like coffee and printer ink everything
right so I'm trying to be an activist
and and I and I would take the subway
home and I had to wear a suit and a tie
and I would take the path and you had to
go under the Hudson and go to Hoboken
and and I'd sit there like that and
there was just and they were all [ __ ]
Goldman Sachs like that there was so
smart they were all so accomplished they
were all like ex-athletes they were just
and they all they all not anymore comes
they're also kind of better looking
they're all like these really it's like
the super people and then I've never
felt like more of a [ __ ] spore like a
troll and then I like I remember Erica's
a lot once you answer my phone's a
little differently I go oh how I guess
well you're like oh that's happy I go oh
I guess I want you to say this is Eric
such-and-such the Eric Schwartz office
how can I help you calm sucks he was
just trying to be clear because you have
to do that stuff answer phones all
[ __ ] day long story short there's an
audition Batman they're looking for
Robin I go my friends okay all right
that's right you'd be great for breath
god I'm Marx in my age in this terrible
agent who this you know it's like one of
those guys a backseat today with a robot
that was that guy
I gotta be Batman he goes I want to be
robbed and he goes oh yeah you want to
be Robin it's already gone out so you're
not gonna be Robin
because what are you thinking he kind of
puts me in my place like it shows me my
odds and all that Bosley's and he wanted
he was putting me up for extra work the
extra room in do it yeah I'm sitting him
I'm sitting on the [ __ ] train and I'm
looking down at the sweat beads on my
forearm it was so hot and I and I and I
was a I was a temp and I went and I
don't know myself when I said I
don't know for the first time my life if
this fairytale I've been telling myself
is going to come true
I don't think anything's going to happen
for me unless I do something desperate
and that was when you know I end up
saying I'm gonna just my ex girl from a
good time said you have to stand up and
that was like I can't just I'm terrified
I would stand up and and then you know
right especially now I get a piss so
hard I'm gonna take a break okay I have
to do company go pee so I'm in get this
hard okay okay great yeah go pick Stuart
do it brother
ready ready Jim hey that that race
you're talking about was it Bighorn it's
debarker Barkley yeah the one that you
look at him look it up the Berkeley the
Berkeley ultramarathon look at Berkeley
be a RK okay
Berkeley le why Berkeley Marathon right
there a Berkeley ultramarathon it's done
rug is the ultra marathon trailer is
held in in frozen head State Park near
Warburg Tennessee runners elect a fun
run of 60 miles to find their way
through it's the bark it's called a
carpet down the wrong thing then I saw
on Cameron a race it either went up
Bighorn 117 thousand feet elevation yeah
better models yeah that's everything the
barking I'm talking about he's tried
that the Bartlett look at Berkeley
ultramarathon then say uh say finisher
okay and look there's been many serie
and click on the Wikipedia link of that
you know it hasn't been met in Berkeley
this is the Vario front of a hundred
miles we had dessert the race is
approximately 60 hour period and then it
said in the description of the it's
limited to 40 runners over a year and to
get into you have to do some weird know
you know where to show up you have no
wish opieop does the other guy who runs
it of si or something right you have to
show up then course registration tiny
other requirements look at it starts any
time for midnight to ruin on race that
you don't know when it starts so this
guy that made up this crazy idea
it's just cause like this cult down here
it is so requirements and submit the
application circa are closely guarded
secret with no details advertised
publicity intentional entrance
complete an essay on why I should be
allowed to run in the box and pay a
dollar sixty are you rolling are you
rolling
we're rolling we're rollin rollin with
all the Berkeley marathon yeah cool hey
debit buddy I know you got to watch the
documentary on it there's a documentary
that's how you can get it on Netflix
iTunes wherever it's pretty it's pretty
me it's just insane the cutoff time for
the hundred mile race is 12 hours
there's guy who finished it I heard camp
Tonka and I think is rodents podcast
about it some up some guy finished you
know you have ten hours right twelve
hours
he finished twelve hours in five seconds
he didn't get his award right the full
five loop race course has been completed
18 times by 15 runners in its history Oh
Mike is pretty nuts right like it dates
back to 1995 is the first finisher Jared
Campbell got twice and look at bring up
Jarrett Campbell honestly looks like
yeah look at the number of years there
are no there's nobody who's been in a
sling like it's look at it from 95 to
2001 nobody finished it it's like
hilarious you gotta watch the
documentary it's really good really it's
a really interesting thing but it's it's
part of that example of tapping into
human beings think they can do anything
right and it's anything is possible and
this is sort of you know the ultimate
expression of that is a smaller fella
yeah I wonder what yeah what the profile
is the physical profile for those other
people who can do it yeah like there's
got to be something on a physical thing
that you have advantage or maybes it's
way more mental than yeah we're way more
to suffer longer the idea and it's I
mean you could mention you could do it
be it's not a physical trait like I
could do it alright big dude I could one
under sense is your mindset yeah if I
said you'll pay you a billion dollars
right now you know run 300 miles you
like you get up right now and you'd run
300 mile I'm going to do it yeah I'm not
stopping yeah not some physical or the
word born different they're either they
just yeah they have a reason beasts will
know them but just mentally though hey
you know belong people are thing they
can deal with it LA there's a lot more
people there mentally comfort than you
are
they're just they're able to just do
things that you claw I would say they
always say the debt that they're able to
not but they're really good learning
what not to think about so that they
when they're running not thinking about
the pain they're just thinking about you
know he didn't really I loved you
the brain is the greatest computer ever
invented and you can figure out anything
if you allow it to so I love I love
using example of golf if you will if you
can stand over a white ball that's still
with a crooked you know a crooked metal
stick and figure out an indeterminate
distance how far to hit it if you're
allow your brain to do it the issue is
when you if you ever like see like an
amateur golfer just step up not think
about it and crushing Wow how's that
because they don't know what they're
doing and then what happens is your
brain gets in the way it's getting the
yips I'm learning what I do wrong
right like you when what you know what
what is wrong about the thing you're
going to be sometimes you find yourself
aiming toward that and when you think
about think about even in the fighting
world right when you let your brain get
out of the way like if you're thinking
too much your screen just you're totally
screwed right you have to allow yourself
to be free and what moves should you do
next is something that's a natural
occurrence that your brain has figured
out because Brandi couture coined the
phrase kinetic chess you know said it's
all kinetic chef and it's the if this
endless scenario of if-then events that
are happening in a split second and it's
not something that you're consciously
thinking about it's something that you
let your mind free because it knows oh
if this then that and you allow it to
happen
I think it's true in even in
ultramarathon it's like look if I just
get out of way of my mind and don't
think about how much pain I'm in and
don't try to overthink this it what's
interesting is when we were talking
about nutrition in these events
Livi's ran the Leadville 100 hundred
miles in Leadville Colorado it starts at
10,000 feet of elevation that's the
highest point for starting the starting
points in the in the country when you
the winner that year that Lizzie ran it
was literally didn't carry any nutrition
just went aid station to aid station and
had water and that was that and over a
hundred miles and I'm like that's that's
kind of my point is that we're like a
lot of people have Camelback they're
weighing it down and you're trying to
run you have all this extra weight and
you're taking in goo and food and stuff
and your body's trying to prot do too
much just let your mind get by you who
are helping us yeah they're always kind
of sick I mean you know our health maps
are always there's always something
wrong where is like you see people who
just don't
ever think about it [ __ ] healthy you
never they never miss a day I worked
with a cap damn it all right that's good
credit history events current events can
you read the first one is a 50th year
old guy fought a 21 year old person
within an hour's notice I guess the
guy's opponent probably fell out and
then he ended up the rumor is that the
guy is actually the illegitimate father
of the kid that he fought or the
illegitimate son Wow Wow
no was it is a professional sanctioned
fight and I killed it this has been
artists or some [ __ ] somewhere else yeah
and he's all hey we need to opponent and
some old do that I'll do it he was just
at a watchin is he beat the [ __ ] of a
son she did and idea to film that this
is footage here who gotta check it out
oh this is a father potentially the
father beating up the kid no no and then
i'll positive what dad's and so what's
the question is this real so Stephan
Bonnar was the one filming it so across
oh my I heard from hey I read the name
stuff in bombing for a drag are we
wondering if this is real or not or
vomit at face value let's see the punch
again because it was I'm not in the
beginning they do actually fight legit
that dad oh yeah angles down that stuff
is not a fixed fight alright oh wait
hold on
all right not legit stuff alright that's
tough so a dad's never fought before
ever have no I would say no we did dad
but no nobody that's technique I don't
know what's going on here dad
okay now dad's pissed hands up that baby
so dad's going to tag them right here
hands up dad right right ands up
no no oh he's so how did we is it true
is he the father and did we find out if
he's legit I couldn't find anything with
Gintama online but that's the rumor that
a dad look like he was smiling before he
did that let me can look at this video
it kind of looks a little decadent wait
hold on why would this any publicity at
all like who would find out this story
and videotape it and probably good
enough and Bonners attached to it I know
it feels a little convenient doesn't it
slightly some guy one hour and I was
very hot vwe it does so weird oh no we
got to pull it out either on the crowd
will do this and now we're talking about
a come live this is like like a backyard
brawl it's ball hit it's low level
fighting for sir but they're not faking
it now they're getting hey I think it
was all days but that's a real fight
yeah okay I think it's staged but that
she hid but they're hitting each other
yeah I think all that stage but it you
know but do you think that like because
it looked like dad could have could have
been done could have been finished do
you think they were like we'll fight
within reason but dad's gotta win I
don't I don't know I don't know it won't
evolve is easily the whole thing is a
[ __ ] jump from whole things that I think
there's a Jeremy I'm gonna raise my hand
and say it's a little too convenient
yeah I'm skeptical as well but you know
the Papa did [ __ ] last shot and drop
Papa got hit in the face without hitting
in the Sun got hit yeah I think what she
deserves definitely that up you know it
was all it was out of like why would
just make a headline I think it's too
convenient that's my opinion
- back I like it next event that's
different
well you guys are know about this yeah
big black died and this is the most
recent thing I found on it his ex-wife
said that he was in the hospital for a
heart condition anyways and his doctor
was saying that he may need a new heart
damn Wow such a bummer man it's a huge
bummer she was such a good dude and on
our show he's such a just a positive
spin but the thing with him and you know
and Rob and see Rob did that heartfelt
message just like man I hate it I can't
believe I'm even riding
my heart's broken be like dog the beef
between Rob and big all that goes out
the window man like that doesn't carries
no weight here it's just such a bummer
and that is such a bummer definitely a
reminder to see you today
yeah so don't know a huge UFC Fan just
uh you know a guy
talk about your brink of midnight you've
been a good guest for you time I guy was
a security guard ends up being you know
the biggest reality show on MTV ever
Robin big and he's you know one part of
that right and they take that turned
into a clothing mogul yeah and he goes
from there and it's just it's a great
story man you know well rest in peace
that's a mama yeah 45 years old you
naughty old I've you're gonna make it
really have a mage's me you know really
out of shape and yeah I don't know if
it's on me of Chris Chris Berman wife do
you hear about that no died in a car
accident alright and Berman chest
retired just retired Jasper Johns I mean
it's a netiquette it says that I've had
I've had the great fortune of you know
meeting in yeah Chris ring a lot I mean
really such a great especially to
someone like me and I have gone up to
him several times and said without you I
mean think about what the lion area was
of changing the way that sport really
brought to creating expressions in
emotion and personality in a way that
we'd never seen and he's such a amazing
in I told him you know it's like I never
would have done what I went what I've
done in my professional career if it
weren't for dude I mean I'm not a I was
a tsdm party and he was in we're talking
and some these two fans got in there and
I Chris oh my god
you know and he talked to these two
drunk bros for probably thirty minutes
just asking about ESPN and Sports and he
is a great guy imagine that's a tragic
again you know it's it's C I mean it's
hard to make sense of it's all we can do
is seize the day and you know pray for
the best and pray for those who are less
fortunate than we are
let's do anyways all right the next one
excellent is the rock she said in a our
Table Talk you that he's actually taking
it seriously that he would
are being regarding for president in
2020 I believe I think this is a problem
I don't think it's good I think Donald
Trump opened this door and now others so
let's be real it's what Donald Trump is
now other people going oh [ __ ] if you
can do it I'm more things for Donald
Trump but you know I can do it too
but I'm gonna the only reason why I
might disagree that's a bad thing is I
think it's I think it's the way that it
was supposed to be set up to begin with
right it wasn't supposed to be just a
class of politician and there was it was
supposed to be the founding fathers
always said George Washington I mean
they're they all I said that you know
this was the our democracy was supposed
to be able to be run by ordinary men
right any I want to order enhance that
knows what he's doing right we have rods
below but let's say this lit let's say
this we ever the Trump experiment is for
the country and that if there's ever
been a brink of midnight moment in this
country Donald Trump right for better or
worse we all are sorted out we're
figuring out gosh should we put someone
like that in the Oval Office
and the answer right now is I don't know
I mean it's like Jeff's violent just
fired Comey you know just a few months
ago
all the Democrats were saying Comey
should be fired Comey should be fired I
can't believe how that's why they're all
going hey yeah we [ __ ] do that up if
you guys are finding stuff out about
Russia is bogus too because the FBI is a
huge place in this it did when you fire
the director in Soho because the way the
rush investigation cuz it just goes with
that guy you don't think there's real
hundreds of other people maybe a lot of
miscalculations like holding a press
conference and stuff but you know I I
don't feel as uneasy about the rock and
I'll tell you why I think he happens to
be highly intelligent highly effective
because your hands are successful oh
yeah he's I think he's I think he's
hiding it I think he works very hard
things very intelligent and I think
someone like the rock is somebody who
probably could learn quickly and I think
I think I'm any different an old horse
figure well he's not arms for stinger
was I mean a fairly effective governor
so do you always you're president I
would have voted for Schwarzenegger
there are a lot of things I agree to I
think he I like the idea right weed I
use experience I but we haven't seen the
results of the
in terms of president we need a wait we
need to wait some time we really is a
very long I've never been a fan of Trump
because of his narcissism but I think
that someone like the rock is somebody I
don't know what is education level is
right and I don't know look I don't know
does it does that I don't know him but I
know I'm having some interviews not when
I'll be very careful also impressed with
his level of how effective he is he
seems to be a very effective
communicator which is a huge part of
being a president he seems to exercise
good judgment just based on the choices
he's made he stays out of trouble and I
don't know I think if my feeling about
this is if he's the kind of guy that
wants to run for president it sounds
like he's interested in politics I
haven't seen any other words man humming
yeah
Kanye West said he wants to run that I
have a problem with that how t any
different
well I think for me Kanye West they're
both dogs eNOS let's just get out of the
way well oh there's a difference I think
that for me kanye west is somebody who's
not only a narcissist but I think honey
West seems erratic right he seems like
he just goes off the deep end and one
one instance and then also deep end
another so I can't track his brain and I
and I so with Kanye would even make more
sense it seems like he's more interested
in and I think I've given him a fair
shake and listened to a lot of what he
said I feel like he's more interested in
the fame with brain worth maybe the rock
I guess I wanted appear to assume the
rock as here here that's intention he's
not doing for fame and he knows politics
right because he's great inside laters
eight he's made good career decisions of
the Mac is it really anything real
careful is this really about the rock to
me it this is not about the rock this is
about the fact that in our minds now as
America possibility possible yeah Tania
what steadily yeah I mean driving my
windows I can you wouldn't win you know
it's kind of like you'd win the popular
vote breaking a run and I asked his
people liking so much yeah but if this
is breaking the four-minute mile Donald
Trump broke the four-minute mile now
everyone's like hey I can do why not why
not why not I got what do you think the
more likely scenario is somebody who
comes from a far more modest background
that seems to be like to have answers
wonderful again seems like I don't well
I would vote for Oprah but first you
wait Oakland we really bother
celebrities I neither fuckton know a lot
there are big differences Tony Robbins
stories I don't know there are there any
differences I mean so so Oprah is
somebody who I happen to think is highly
intelligent and and has exposed us Adele
yeah that's right but no but she's
exposed herself to a lot of what has
been thought and said in the best of
ways with good intentions she's also
she's also made differences like Oprah
Winfrey deliberately said I'm going to
have a show that is based on education
inspiration you know with our Oprah book
club and so someone like Oprah who's
eminently reasonable and a thinker I
would feel way more comfortable in my
problem has always been with Donald
Trump that he's about himself first and
foremost to a pathological degree right
I mean I think if I can't have a slower
review president I think I love the rock
narcissist
I like Kanye West's narcissist Oprah
Winfrey narcissist Tony Robbins
narcissus to get to that level of Fame
into to really be successful in
entertainment you have to be a bit of a
nurse there do you or do you have to be
somebody who like for example Tony
Robbins seems to be actually not at so
much a narcissist Tony Robbins seems to
be a guy who studied the human brain and
how human beings behave and got really
good at effecting change in large groups
of people I mean at this is somebody who
I listen all those tapes ready to make
fun of them and was swayed in a big way
I was very little interest don't know
from I listen all his tapes back in the
day cuz I was writing a movie a guru
so so someone like that might be a
little bit different because someone
like Tony Robbins I think is driven by
the idea that you want to end human
suffering he is I mean you can call him
idealistic he thinks he's guided and
that's his drive and that's what drives
me got more money than God um so it's
maybe a lot most a billion dollars yeah
here's what I would say again this isn't
about Dwayne Johnson and I think with my
opinion I think the next outsider that
becomes president I like that idea that
it's not just another politician it's an
outsider but I think it would be an
unlikely person that we don't even know
of today that we all as a country are
going to really listen now we're going
to say you know what we need to not be
caught up
by just the little headlines in the
little social media we need to actually
listen to what people are saying and
that next person that x-out send their
attention is someone who we go you know
what they're not super famous not super
risky I don't but see whimpering what
Brennan saying I go catch fire you got
to be careful not to be attracted to
what's shining diner anyone well you
would probably on the mall yeah does
excitable traction you need more
comfortable probably the way I would
with somebody who who for example was a
really good businessman and killed it in
the borders were the kind of a guy a
grandpa who's far to the left but even a
guy like Elon Musk right who has this
crazy idea doesn't want to be sane as I
don't see him out in the tap he's
innovative he's thoughtful he knows how
the economy works
he's have to deal with the economy like
that I know it a lot of those people
right here you're right I mean we're
even richer than Trump a lot of people
who are like super famous they're going
to see this experiment and say oh I
don't want to do that but I would argue
that people are going to pay out I like
right I would and you hurt Trump Donald
Trump even it's mine maybe I don't
yeah Howard Stern talked about Howard
service talk about how you know he gets
paid whatever 375 million dollars from
series here's the life he goes the
studio he owns everything it's bit life
is great then America got challenges
we'd love for you do the showing us why
not in people like it's a big commitment
as I a lot it's a cool experiment and I
guess next thing you know I'm on set
[ __ ] four days a week I'm missing
myself now I'm sitting around in my
trailer for three hours a day wall this
lady gets her makeup on and I've got all
these commitment deals I [ __ ] up man I
feel like Trump's the same way it looks
good from the outside don't you actually
you're into like oh my mark I brass up
my life America's Got Talent the White
House same I was pre mounted below I
would be surprised Trump does not run up
for a second absolutely not I came back
to my he glanced at Trump she's been
White House once and then they're good
and now he's barely this weekend third
third now yeah yeah when he comes in
says we're gonna fix it all right away
and it's like oh man I need cooperation
because although
he goes from this penthouse he's living
in to the west winding down good kids
like oh we write these rooms a tiny rose
oh yeah I mean do I like that's like
this is a down after a while you'd be
enough for we got ears
I signed a four-year lease yeah laughter
how's your ass everybody's around you
all the time do you have no private I
want to know
Pecha cheese maker huge was the stress
not a stress and could he actually
renovate the White House like what's the
palette or not absolutely can't said
you're leasing that place but we don't
like does anybody look at the contract
and say you're allowed to put furniture
at the desk stays okay you're allowed to
put your own furniture entertaining the
wallpaper no well nice going sir I can I
added we know hold on hold on would you
say no he can't
here's the question can Donald Trump
change the wall Nellore when you say no
he can't well then who can't he can do
out of a [ __ ] you want well I do you
problem what do you mean there's some
others like you can't put it like you
can make the Oval Office like a
nightclub but like it now but I'm sure
the slack out of impunity process I'm
just saying there's somebody in the
world who can say you know what we need
to change it to committee there Carter
we did a little oral our show so all the
beautiful Bob will put in a basketball
court right yeah yeah typically you can
as soon as long as I'll get the [ __ ] out
of here I just want I don't know the
answer that club we're with the Paula
right now what is the policy of changing
the decor like if I wanted a bowling
never in then well there is an answer so
you can change the decor so you can come
in with your own drapes your own so
every four Dudley's here additionally
would come in all right you know Adam
yeah raised in the room hey here's
another question
tell me idea here's another one let's
say the rock ran for president and he's
a single man and he wants to have a
couple couple ladies every night he's
single 9s not do you think can he can
you do that here's the other question
can you put a mirror on the ceiling
yeah Marco who know yeah the problem is
what else you got Jim all right the next
one is a study about marijuana so they
did the study in Germany and it was a
group of mice young mice mature mice and
then super
old mice and apparently the old mice it
helped their brain brain how so I'm not
there was like a cabin type thing that
gets reenacted in your brain that helps
with cognitive behavior there it is
we just raised my hand in all them all
the marijuana studies pro pro or con
marijuana guy me yeah kind of neutral I
don't I don't drink alcohol caffeine I
do drugs and no kind so I'm kind of I'm
just like a watered okay water I know
prosecute like I and I honestly when it
comes to marijuana I think it's I
personally feel like the fact that there
are people in jail for a long design
over something like this is like like
they're bigger issues but here's my
issue that I have with studies like this
there they have marijuana and then they
have no marijuana
aren't there a gazillion other things we
could also test to see what kind of
results they produce and when you say
wow marijuana let them eight you know
last longer is there something else
that's better than marijuana yeah so
firstly listen our kids ahead of our
part because the bottom line is you have
to draw causality so all these studies
are our science is the process of
explaining what we observe right I heard
that on Sam Harris's podcast on sailing
it but but causality is very very
difficult because there are so many
other mitigating circumstances so you
have to take into account so many other
different things when you draw these
correlations based on my first of all
human bodies work very differently it's
just take it all with a grain of salt
man right because it's really difficult
to establish causality they've done so
many studies on humans and you've got to
make sure other things are staying still
and they're never staying still and you
also especially have to look at who's
doing the study what's the motivation
behind it there's a lot of money funded
yeah there's a lot of money be made I
mean if you look at look at articles
from the 1950s of how awesome cigarette
smoking is there's no effect on you it
look there's also there's a lot of
studies showed that that THC and
cannabis oil and can help in stopping
tumors and then there's a lot of times
it can take and help and not doing
anything at all to them and all that
look if you look if you look up the
placebo effect yeah it's real find a lot
of a lot of studies that show that
placebos are as effective as
chemotherapy in treating cancer yeah so
when we look at this Meryl
a study your kind of you can set up
anything and find what you want so what
do you believe then what should you
really about these sites all full of
[ __ ]
I I think I think we all need to have a
healthy sense of skepticism on quote on
every set or release on either direction
muttering I just think your moderation I
like to me what life is really simple
like eat like it's common sense what you
should eat don't live off of cotton
candy
I don't live off of marijuana it also
depends on your body by the way I don't
when you're only doing right so if I
smoke weed I'm a complete idiot like I
could never drive one week and I know
people that smoke weed everyday and are
very highly functioning I my body type
my chemistry doesn't work with with THC
I'm a designer I don't know about that
if you did as much as they did you would
get more used to it I like the way I
feel well but you don't do it very much
so if you just do it once ago my body's
exact welder's but if you did as much as
these people you're talking about yeah
body but I just don't think I would be
I could function for the my size for
this my study I would just raise my hand
and say they're my healthy sense of
skepticism yeah besides 400 I'm not
their dies is not the be-all end-all my
god you absolutely need this what I
don't think is ridiculous that the Roger
Goodell won't even entertain the idea
that marijuana helps a lot of players
yeah and the means until prescribed all
sorts of horrible painkillers my my life
issue I have when you go don't can't do
that we can't take that yeah but I we
know relax that is worse for your body
the man you know for a fact and you
won't even obtain it but the view it to
me on the proper view on call it I mean
peds whatever whatever it is is if
there's enough science behind it that we
all can say yeah you know what vitamin C
is good for you like we we know vitamin
C is good for you like we all can agree
on that you say yeah ibuprofen reduces
inflammation and we if we can say yeah
aspirin can acts as a mild blood thinner
we can all agree on that
you're allowed to take these certain
things we all agree on marijuana we're
not there as a society right there is a
country so bladder Goodell is overseeing
a national product and you can't take
just state laws into account of saying
it's legal and debt in Colorado but it's
not legal and
another state you know he's got to look
at me and you can look at the National
picture and there's more deaths from
those prescribed painkillers aiya I
agree with you a million percent on that
that Ben that's amore maternai ain't it
though right the only I probably problem
is a whole it many have players going
this this will make me play better on
Thursday
it helps my pain my inflammation are we
gonna [ __ ] what the mouse study says or
whatever you believe this helps me which
is a better product on the field which
pays you more money but canederli
against the law so he can't make that
judge can't make that he's running a
national origin teammate is to find
those players and to not let him play
that they test positive for like a
Joshua Cribs who's a homerun all-pro
here how about this I think it's
actually illegal I think I think we
should be legal and then we won't have
this issue but I do think he's he might
be in a rock and a hard place because
he's got a been sanctioned something
that's federally illegal and he has a
very have it as a country we haven't
settled this I mean especially with
Trump in the White House it's a he's
yeah meantime marijuana the issue they
can old kind of the old issues on
stoners and pot heads and then did I
know I won't look at right I've been
around those guys in high school it's
like you're 60 right port I know you
were times have changed now totally well
whatever I I will look at this with
skepticism well they did stress that
it's it is in mice it's not in humans
that's right and they're also saying
that the good part of it is it's helping
the older mice not the younger mice
right so it's actually helping the
brains of the older month I've heard
marijuana for like you know 16 the
really 26 can be trouble man because
your body's but developing right how
about this if it's not it's not
naturally in you like if it's like you
think about it it of course especially
the way that we're ingesting anything
externally right it's smoking is bad for
you no matter what that's a be ingesting
is being like wow it's altering the way
that I feel there has to be something to
drop its a drug it's a right does an
apple you all of a sudden you're like
wow I'm feel totally different like give
you all this as I must show you really
day there are but there are mushrooms
that make you feel perfectly normal and
mushrooms that make you
loosening obviously those hallucinations
if you just extrapolate out and say if I
did this all the time every day non-stop
will be any negative repercussions
Broadway probably I boy you're not doing
an apple every hour on me on the hour
every day non-stop do nothing there's
probably some kickback for I do three
shot where Josh shredded like crucial
why he knows if I do three shots it's
going to be gruff grain alcohol chances
are it's going to have an effect on my
if you drink why Josh but too much of it
you'll dilute your electrolytes and die
yeah right now there's anything I don't
like anybody like they like it like
everything everything in moderation and
obviously if it alters your state of
mind just probably some kind of well we
tend to swing back and forth like tether
all this or all that we're John Brenkus
basically in country we are and that's
when you we asked my opinion on it like
I'm I'm a I don't touch anything of any
kind because I know I'd be an awful
terrible drug addict because I'd be like
all in you be done better afraid I don't
I'm always like I'm not gonna have
anything because I know I can't control
this yeah with the suggestions you get
on time John yeah yeah I need a I have
fun alright cool it's do two more two
more a climb Rose caught trying to sneak
through Mount Everest without paying for
his permit and he was found inside a
hiding inside a cave and the permit
would have cost about like $8,000 damn
acceptation are dollars to climb a
mountain over southern Illinois to
21,000 feet who for how not my question
hey what's the tray up there who's like
hold on did you page right oh yeah I did
go give me a second are we a ranger up
there going where's your permit yeah
what kind of dick rangerous out about
eight thousand thirty thousand in the
air okay where's this guy from was at
South African monkey Halloween he had to
get to he had to fly from South I mean
was really expensive all times I do not
came you're not getting there cheaply
and hiding in a cave like we see you
you're not repelling I'm gonna see here
with the into the other guy was he in
the cave with his hand over his eyes
going you can't see me freezing his ass
off so I said he goes I am going to be
honest and saying that when I arrived at
base camp it became evident that I
didn't have nearly enough money for a
solo permit because of hitting cost and
even if I did they would have declined
it because I had no previous
mountaineering experience on my record
well that's it one of the reasons they
do it they don't want you to go up there
and die right it would have been a total
embarrassment to turn around and ascent
defeat except to be because of a piece
of paper because I was ashamed I can
afford the permit after all to help
preparation what everybody had done for
those during my training right so 8 on
if he if he turned around no one ever
knows that he even tried now everybody
knows he tried and failed and it's all
over the internet but also if you're
gonna go hunting you get your hunting
license you have to like are certain
things like hey hey make sure you got
that thing that you mean yeah it's a
checklist but I've had in college
he has no idea no idea that he had
enough money because of hidden like
hidden whatever fix it this is to me
this is silly
next next damn he says my passport has
been counted and a pink lamb in for jail
time silly for climbing a mountain with
no money well if you lose a lot of money
when they don't pay right like the other
shippers have to work during all that
stuff those Sherpas trying to get away
with not paying ice-t I don't lie now
today but this whole day this is all
about a guy I mean he wasn't doing this
as a publicity stunt it's just a guy not
sure why Lincoln grew yeah he didn't
think things through before doing it
like yeah yeah well that's good so I'm
not the first time he's [ __ ] up let's
see how about this one here so P Diddy
had a chef that he would always request
her to come in and feed him after or
during sex with a bunch of different
girls and he would be naked and now
she's she's suing him because he fired
her for allegedly stealing a watch but
apparently the girl was like complaining
to another attendant saying like oh this
is what's happening this is abuse for
the attendant found a way to rig it so
that she was accused of stealing the
watch
yikes so that may just seem like GFI for
stealing yeah hold on let me get this
straight
he's just having tons of sex with
different girls she'd bring him as
chicken wings and I said no racist or
whatever don't make her do it take
whatever and then she would have to hook
up with him to not
okay you would make her come in during
sex or right after sex when everyone's
naked it was electrolytes and [ __ ] girl
did you got a good gig
you got a good kid I don't see the
problem here I get it she's mad that and
she's upset she's whistle blowing now I
mean did like we said these guys stories
are the exact kind of stories that don't
interest me all that much what kind do
it like well you know you can't talk
about it but I know you as the owner of
business have been sued for the dumbest
[ __ ] on the planet well like every bit
of it every business owner at some point
encounter stuff really huh exactly like
what are you talking about and you
realize how little people are yeah and
when I say like the longer you own a
business more clearly you see the evil
that men do but you know what like are
you kidding me these kind of stories
don't even enter my mind because like I
don't know he's telling the truth on
whatever and you better do everything
and I don't but also I don't know dude
he wants a recovery shake after he gets
balls even a few girls right
Huber's pretend your job yeah you gotta
be replenished yeah I need my vitamins
yeah lady God good news
wait I need my vitamins Oh take that
take that total three other girls yeah
guy you welcome this you John didn't
come on the show I ain't come on any I
do so glad it John that's it
boom breakage ah he did he keep doing
this thing hey guys break a midnight is
the podcast this Monday I made with Ray
Lewis III know that John's great
interview it's gonna be great sounds
like a great like just studying like
people are very effective and when they
had their moment of change exactly and
everybody can subscribe to it right now
go to iTunes stitcher google play go to
brink of midnight calm you can go you
can find it it's not brink it's bring
brink Bri and your a ring of midnight
boom because coming on man I gotta
really appreciate it be and they can see
you this you got y'all can see me that's
frickin that tomorrow
well tonight because you're gonna get
this probably on Thursday Thursday
Friday Saturday at the Denver Comedy
Works down
town never don't see my boy come out
almost sold out her Assam yes
yeah it's exciting you guys are the best
both of you
Thank You fun writing it might be
funnier than Brian now I don't know
close close no I am appreciation area
I'm showing you buy yourself some
tickets that's all there's a lot of
[ __ ] still get tickets see fat K calm
Brian I will both be in Oklahoma May 20
sets next Saturday arcade cocina
that's next Saturday you need casino
Oklahoma Arkansas Arkansas border it's
kind of a weird area Cherokee Casino
TPAC a calm for all those tickets think
that's it thanks for coming on John John
to you this is the final kid we're out